we don't really do much of an
introduction all then i will just say
i'm going to welcome my friend pete
holmes
to the show hey p that's it
that's it okay great i am welcomed
i feel welcome it's so nice to see you i
miss you man i really do
a lot of work goes into a short late
night stand-up set join me
jp buck as i spotlight the comedians who
came up with some of my favorite coin
sets
this is the setup please welcome the
very funny
pete holmes
i had been submitting sets i really
wanted to be on conan by the time i was
30. it was only it was one of the very
few
um specific like actual goals i had
certain goals but they were all sort of
like rainbows they were vague and
i don't know some magical feeling in the
future but i was like
i want to do conan by the time i'm 30.
and i based that on
almost nothing and i was 31
i used to joke that i blamed my divorce
because that sort of like ate a year of
my life it sort of slowed me down
but i was right i was right on time when
i was trying to get on letterman you'd
send them a five minute tape
and then they'd be like we like it
except maybe this joke then you'd send
them another it would take another month
to get a five-minute tape that you liked
with that joke removed and this one in
where i'm like if you just sent a longer
tape you could be like
yeah okay you want a different 30
seconds here you go but that's not even
what got it for me
is then you happened to be at the improv
on melrose
and i was doing i was going on last and
i was so happy that you were there
because this is what everybody thinks
show business says like the booker for
conan will be in the crowd
and you were there and we had been
exchanging tapes and stuff
and you watched me and i did the google
bit
and then this is such
good timing it's like you liked the
google bit and you wanted to premiere it
on conan which was like the best news
ever
and i had already taped it for the john
oliver show which is what conan plugs
in the intro so i'm like isn't it funny
we're plugging the show that features
the bit that's breaking on this show to
beat that show
i was like any time if you're pitching a
tv show or a set or
any idea if there's anything that can
put a clock on it that can be like
we need to do this before this it's
always helpful and
and i feel like that greased the wheels
it actually kind of works that i'm
wearing this terrible shirt it's like a
smock
for painting it's just like like nobody
tells you what to wear like i just kind
of came in that shirt
and um it's it's too big and but it that
that
helped because when i say um i'm not a
cool guy i don't know if you can tell by
my overall vibe that's the first
joke yep i don't think they would have
laughed if i hadn't
done something sort of fumbly bumbly
up top and that actually included how i
looked like if i was wearing a suit or
something
and i said i don't know if you can tell
i'm not a cool guy if i look like
melanie or something you'd be like
no you seem like a pretty cool guy like
you're sharp and
well-dressed so even the the outfit was
sort of telling the first joke
i think it was um seinfeld or maybe
chris rock
that talked about you always um waved
waved to the host
and waved to the band and they were like
that's the quickest way to look like a
professional
yeah okay that was exciting
uh how's it going everybody
it came out and i just wanted them to
laugh at me smiling
standing there and when they didn't i'm
sort of like how are you like i'm trying
to establish
up top which of course you do live but
it's
even more important i think for tv sets
it's like
i'm you're watching me but i'm watching
you
i don't want to feel like i'm showering
on stage and you're watching me i want
to be like i say this to crowds i go
you're you're
evaluating me i'm evaluating you like
i'm going to talk to other people about
how you
were yeah this is not and that and
that's to get them sort of in a
performative place i want to get this
out of the way right up top i'm not a
cool person i don't know if you can uh
tell already from my overall vibe
i don't know if this is gonna make sense
but i'm 31 years old i don't have any
kids but i'm already kind of like a fun
dad can you get that sense for me just
like the
dorky dad at a barbecue
fresca that guy singing hip-hop wrong to
children just like well so you can have
whatever you need yeah
snacks on dad patron no patron
fun dab like i don't have kids but if i
did i'd be the kind of dad they're
having a sleepover
i'd keep barging in embarrassing them
with the tray of food just like tuna
melts
dad's style that's extra mayo
if you like it then you should put some
trees on it
get out of here chad if you like it then
you shouldn't put your feet on it
seriously kyle the ottoman is decorative
so
you didn't know you didn't know this bit
at this point i believe in your career
was longer i remember there's a
non-smoking queen joke
yeah no it was longer the non-smoking
queen thing was
when john mulaney he and i were touring
together
and i was checking into a hotel and this
is just real they said
uh one of our rooms is a non-smoking
queen and i went that's me
and um that's when john said
you're like a fun dad and i said and
this is what any
comedian should say when another
comedian makes fun of them
can i have that and it wasn't
um we recreated it on crashing
we had um jamie's character say to me
you're like a fun dad because i wanted
to show that that's where
often jokes come from is instead of
having your feelings hurt when another
comedian it's like if another community
makes fun of you
get out your notepad like this is how
the world sees you this is probably how
the audience
doesn't know maybe they see you but when
you say it you go like oh right that
that's a great line
[Music]
so i have an eye telephone i have an i
telephone
thank you real quick that was a hot line
that was a hotline i love my telephone
it's a silly little laugh at the top
but here this moment where you grab the
mic you actually requested
a certain mic i said like you have a
handheld you have a wireless
little love mic that that way your hands
are free but you would said to me i want
a wireless mic on a mic stand because i
need to like
lean into this yeah you said it's the
physical
physicality of you stepping forward on
this bit was very important
it's like grabbing a lever or something
like it's this thing and i haven't
touched it the whole set
no for the most part and it almost looks
like a dance partner like you're taking
it
like you're gonna dip it and then it
gives you this like
it also feels like a weapon now it's
like i have i'm armed i have this
this like spear and this like heavy
based mace
that i'm gonna like and the and the
energy my energy completely
shifts and knowing that i could grab
this sort of merlin
staff and go like all right
[ __ ] you listen to me
um because you sat through that
silliness and you stayed with me i love
you now
and and my hope is to give you something
that we can all enjoy but
like i'm not around anymore you know i
have google on my phone i'm guessing a
lot of you do i have google on my phone
now
it's ruining our lives i don't know if
you've noticed it's ruining
life because we know everything
but we're not a lick smarter for it we
just know
you don't know something wait two
seconds
you will know having google on your
phone
is like having a drunk know-it-all in
your pocket
there's no time for mystery or wonder
you're just like
how do they make glass
and you know but the time between
not knowing and knowing is so brief
that knowing feels exactly like
not knowing so life is meaningless
the craziest thing about this joke is
that it was a fresh
take like when i say i have google on my
phone
that was kind of a newer thing that
meant like i have a fancy phone
and only probably 33 of the crowd
probably had a smartphone at that time
so it was like breaking news like i i
have especially when i first started
telling the joke
i've literally been in bed in the
morning alone just like
where's tom petty from
[Laughter]
but i feel nothing because there was no
time to not
know listen to me there was a time
and i don't mean to get all andy rooney
on you
but there was a time that if you didn't
know where tom petty was from
you just didn't know
and you felt that yearning and that
deficit in your being
and you'd go around and ask actual
people
like where's tom petty from i don't know
i don't know
i don't know and now i'm impregnated
with wonder
and then they go and ask people until
one fateful day you see a girl wearing a
heartbreakers t-shirt
you rush up to her and you're like hey
where's tom petty from
and she tells you florida and a wave of
endorphins
and pleasure and meaning would wash over
you
and you felt something and that's how
you met your wife
do you understand your wedding song was
refugee
this was the first sort of joke that i
was like i will not forget how i feel
about uh smartphones and google because
i care and you and that's where the
grabbing the mic and that's when i'm
yelling
but it's earned and and the pace picks
up i'm watching one man struggle with
his search for tom petty which is
so inconsequential because what are you
gonna do with this information but then
at the end
the payoff is look what that was that
was a click moment for me
was to try and tie it back to something
human like it's not just that you want
to know
it's that the conversation leads to
meeting someone because not knowing
leads you to going up to a woman in a
shirt so that that was like that's when
i realized it was a bit
you know you had a rant and then you
were like oh there's a moment where
they'll
they'll clap because they'll know that
it's over because you
brought the beginning to the end life is
meaningless and before it used to be
like this um
so it's super super exciting
[Music]
blanken empty says this would be funnier
if he wasn't wearing that shirt
it is funnier because i'm wearing a
terrible shirt but we can agree that
it's a terrible shirt
yes yes i think everyone that lands on
the side of it's a terrible shirt
it's now my bedspread it's very soft
this is from
radical moose lim i like the guy he
makes great skits on comedy central and
he's a good actor
a good public speaker with a lot of
important things to say
but he's not that funny for the most
part
[Laughter]
i you know there's my favorite story
i don't know who the comedian was but it
was at standup new york
i think mullany told it to me i don't
know if he saw it firsthand
but he was killing and there was one guy
in the front that wasn't laughing
and the guy in the middle of his set
leaned down to the guy that wasn't
laughing
and he said i agree with you but we're
outnumbered
that's sort of how i feel when
somebody's like that wasn't that funny
i'm like i agree with you but we're
outnumbered
thankfully we're outnumbered i think
more people like that gable says
always thought this guy was a bozo but
he's actually quite funny here and i've
been an [ __ ]
hashtag i'm sorry pete holmes oh my god
let's get that trending
i that to me is is extra special
there's nothing better than somebody
i've had that too where you're just like
maybe you look like somebody uh you look
like my ex-boyfriend or
or you look like this guy that bullied
me there's all of this
projection going on that we we prejudge
people and we don't give them a chance
and i do it every single day too
but when someone can win them over and
find some common ground
that's what laughing is you know it's so
special to get everybody laughing
together but if there's somebody that
came in that was like
this guy and then at the end they're
like that was okay
that's sort of like one of the rarest
jewels in the stand-up cave and
that's extra special
i never thought that this set would lead
to all the things that we've done
together and that doesn't include
our you know our dates to you know
industry events where you've been right
plus one jp
always brought me is this plus one okay
here's all the ways you have to include
this
the jp helped my career he gave me my
first late night tv show
which was with conan then when they made
a list of people that could possibly
have a show with conan he submitted my
name
then produced on my show the pete holm
show
and then while that was happening i
would go to the hbo emmy party with jp
asses plus one because i was not invited
and it was at that party that i first
talked with jeff
john apatow who ended up producing and
judd was a fan of the pete holm show
so i i don't know if i'll ever be able
to do it but if i win an award
it's always my fantasy to get up thank
the people that were involved in that
project and then say
i'd also like to thank j.p buck jeff
ross conan o'brien you know what i mean
like
david kissinger uh all the people that
worked on that show
i i think the optics might be bad but
that is my fantasy to be like
it's not this show it's all the things
that lead up to that show
and that's when you really need it you
really need someone that goes
i like this guy when you're just a
comedian you know
sweating it out at the improv lab on
melrose
and jp says let's give this guy a shot
that means the world so any chance i get
you have to leave that in
any chance i get i i have to thank you
jp i appreciate that at the same time
like
it was a pretty easy decision to make to
bring you on the show
so very nice of you um and i'm just also
very happy that it's led to a
you know to a great friendship too and
so it's this was as close as we can get
to hanging out backstage so i'm glad
that we got to do this